[Música]
[Aplausos]
las sapiens nos preguntamos sobre
nosotras mismas
quién soy cuál es el sentido de mi vida
porque de morir y nos preguntamos
también sobre las cosas que nos rodean
qué es el bien es este cuadro que acabo
de pintar arte en qué consiste la
felicidad
estos y muchos otros interrogantes
universales a pesar de no admitir
respuestas definitivas nos resultan
ineludibles y nos proporcionan marcos de
reflexión trascendentales podemos
afirmar que son preguntas
intrínsecamente relevantes
de entre las cosas que nos rodean hay
una en la que estamos tan inmersas que
nos resulta realmente difícil pensar la
cosa en sí me estoy refiriendo al tiempo
entonces creo que tenemos 11 minutos
para conocer la aproximación de la
física contemporánea
al interrogante universal que es el
tiempo vamos allá
desde tiempos inmemorables las humanas
hemos habitado un universo de tres
dimensiones
esta mesa la podemos caracterizar por su
alto ancho y largo todas nosotras nos
podemos mover a la antilla tras la
izquierda y a derecha y arriba y abajo
aunque normalmente nos movemos
combinando estas tres dimensiones
todo cambió en 1905 cuando albert
eisntein con su teoría de la relatividad
especial nos enseñó a entender el tiempo
como una dimensión más
la dimensión temporal es bastante
particular y por eso costó tanto
pensarlo así
una de sus peculiaridades consiste en
que solo podemos movernos adelante en el
tiempo y nunca atrás es más estamos
obligadas a avanzar tampoco nos está
permitido quedarnos quietas en el tiempo
así que si amigas eso de las cremas
rejuvenecedoras es una estafa
con todo desde 1905 habitamos un
universo de cuatro dimensiones tres
dimensiones espaciales y una dimensión
temporal muy especial y todas ellas se
relacionan inseparablemente entre sí
permitidme por lo tanto hablar del
espacio-tiempo todo junto permitidme
representar este espacio tiempo de
cuatro dimensiones como una cuadrícula
aquí vemos el espaciotiempo cuadrícula y
además vemos como los cuerpos con masa
de forman el espacio-tiempo a mayor masa
mayor deformación del espacio-tiempo
la situación viene a ser la de un
colchón que cede frente al peso de unas
bolas donde el colchón haría las veces
de espacio-tiempo
este fenómeno lo desveló einstein
también pero en 1915 con su mejorada
teoría de la relatividad general
cuando digo que el espacio-tiempo se
deforma quiero decir que las dimensiones
espaciales se curvan y que la dimensión
temporal se dilata
lo de la deformación del espacio es
exactamente como veis en este gif
tridimensional
por otra parte lo de la dilatación
temporal significa que cuanto más nos
acercamos a un cuerpo con masa más
lentamente transcurre el tiempo
esto que puede resultar sorprendente a
priori es un hecho constatable
por ejemplo el núcleo de nuestro planeta
tierra es dos años y medio más joven que
su superficie
a ver hagamos un inciso porque yo creo
que hay gente preocupada ya
no preocupeis si ganáis unos kilitos de
más de acuerdo las bolas de la imagen y
del gif hay que pensarlas como planetas
como estrellas como cuerpos enormemente
masivos ninguna de nosotras ni
esforzándonos y vamos a poder deformar
el espacio-tiempo de forma que nos
resulte perceptible en este sentido el
espacio-tiempo es como las abuelas que
nos ven siempre hechas unas sílfides a
las que les falta un platito más de su
excelente le guiso
cierro el inciso volvemos al
espacio-tiempo deformado por las grandes
masas de los planetas las estrellas etc
la deformación más extrema del
espacio-tiempo se produce en las
inmediaciones de un agujero negro
supermasivo y haberlos haylos por
ejemplo al que está situado en el centro
de la galaxia m87
pues hasta le hemos sacado una foto
supongamos que yo soy una estrella
bastante incauta y me he acercado más de
lo que me convendría a uno de estos
agujeros negros supermasivos entonces el
tirón gravitacional del agujero negro me
va a desgarrar esto es me va a arrancar
finas corrientes de material que va a ir
succionando y yo pobrecita yo voy a
dejar de ser una hermosa esfera para
convertirme en un espagueti
ya os reís pero es que esto os lo cuento
super en serio las astrofísicas llaman a
este proceso es para certificación
y hacen simulaciones por ordenador del
asunto os enseño una
en el centro intuimos el agujero negro
supermasivo ay bien en amarillo la
encanta estrella amarilla que esférica
que poco a poco va siendo succionada por
el agujero negro hasta quedar totalmente
especificada
en este punto si le preguntamos a la
estrella oye qué hora es la estrella nos
va a responder con una larguísima lista
de horarios distintos entre sí en
concreto a la cola a punto de ser
succionada por el agujero negro le
parecerá que apenas han pasado unos
instantes desde que se paseaba por el
cosmos como parte de una estrella
esférica sin embargo a la cabeza de la
estrella que aún se resiste al tirón
gravitacional le parecerá que su cola
tarda una eternidad en ser devorada por
el agujero negro
pues tanto la cola como la cabeza tienen
razón a pesar de no coincidir en su
medida del tiempo transcurrido
el desacuerdo es sólo aparente y se
produce porque como habíamos dicho el
tiempo transcurre más lentamente cuanto
más nos acercamos a un cuerpo masivo el
agujero negro en este caso
abrochados el cinturón que dejamos atrás
las estrellas en los planetas la
inmensidad del espacio sideral y nos
vamos a ir encogiendo encogiendo
encogiendo hasta llegar aquí al palacio
de congresos europa donde podemos ganar
unos kilitos de más sin miedo a
ralentizar el tiempo que percibimos
y no paramos nos seguimos encogiendo
encogiendo encogiendo encogiendo y nos
vamos a ir directamente al mundo de lo
inconmensurable mente pequeño
nos vamos a hacer tan diminutas que nos
va a parecer que los núcleos atómicos
son mil veces más grandes de lo que las
galaxias nos parecen en nuestro tamaño
original
ahora que somos más diminutas de lo que
nos es humanamente posible concebir
tratemos de ver cómo es que el espacio y
el tiempo se relacionan inseparablemente
entre sí en las profundidades cuánticas
para ver la estructura microscópica del
espacio-tiempo lo primero que tenemos
que hacer es encender la luz encendemos
pues la bombilla más pequeña que existe
un fotón un cuánto de luz
inmediatamente veremos que aparece y
desaparece un micro agujero negro
parémonos a comprender lo que ha
sucedido
veamos
hemos metido al fotón en un volumen del
espacio-tiempo tan minúsculo que la
densidad de energía ha resultado lo
extraordinariamente enorme como para
producir el agujero negro que
rápidamente se ha evaporado
ya lo dijo einstein no solo la masa sino
cualquier tipo de energía de forma el
espacio-tiempo aquí la energía cinética
del fotón es la responsable
los que este experimento mental del
fotón que necesariamente crea un agujero
negro no nos dicen nada sobre la
estructura microscópica del
espacio-tiempo
pero si implica que debemos convivir con
la incapacidad de su determinación
la física no sabe sondear el interior de
los agujeros negros al menos por el
momento
de modo que nos quedamos sin saber cuál
es la estructura fundamental del
espacio-tiempo
qué chasco eh
podría ser podría ser que el universo
tenga límites a nuestro conocimiento que
no a nuestra curiosidad
las hace llamadas longitud y tiempo de
plank donde nos hemos sorprendido con la
aparición y desaparición del micro
agujero negro
ninguna magnitud física ninguna parece
poder determinarse con una precisión
superior a este diminuto intervalo del
espacio-tiempo y esto incluye al
espacio-tiempo mismo
claro que también podría ser que toda la
física que hemos aprendido hasta ahora
tenga que ser reemplazada por una nueva
y aún misteriosa física que engloba
muchos éxitos pasados y esclarezca lo
que a día de hoy se nos antoja
inalcanzable
a mí la física contemporánea me tiene
fascinada os lo digo desde ya pero
volvemos a nuestro tamaño original
volvamos al palacio de congresos europa
yo me esforzado mucho en recalcar que
nuestras experiencias cotidianas distan
mucho de fenómenos como la espacio
tipificación de una estrella o la
creación y evaporación de micro agujeros
negros y verdaderamente no conozco a
nadie que vaya por la calle
encontrándose cosas así
ahora bien no es menos cierto que toda
nuestra rutina se ve directamente
afectada por estos sucesos por ejemplo
no tendríamos gps y por lo tanto
googlemaps en el móvil de no ser por la
relatividad general ni habría tostadora
de no ser por la física cuántica
veis que la física contemporánea es
operacional a pesar de sus profundísimas
ignorancias
ya os digo que yo estoy completamente
cautivada no dejo de sorprenderme y
fascinarme por sus polaridades me siento
irresistiblemente atraída hacia sus
límites e indagó si éstos son aparentes
o fundamentales esto es si se producen
por una incompletitud del marco teórico
la física o si por el contrario y bien
podría ser habitamos un universo que es
inherentemente indescifrable
si pudiera me compraría un billete
directo al espacio-tiempo cuántico para
averiguarlo ya mismo
pero no tengo bien y tal vez nunca nadie
lo tenga
aún y todo el espacio-tiempo existe y
sobre el todo cuanto nos rodea y
nosotras haciéndonos preguntas
esta tarde mi última pregunta es para ti
que afrontas tantas incertidumbres
encontrarás en la física una musa y
sospechada
[Aplausos]